نحن على بعد 12 ساعة من مدينة
المكسيك
في منطقة الجبال العالية
[موسيقى]
إنها منطقة مهمشة وهي منطقة
السكان الأصليين هو المنطقة التي تفتقر
العديد من الموارد لممارسة الجراحة
في هذا النوع من المستشفيات
[موسيقى]
قررت إحضار دواء منخفض التكلفة من
سهولة الوصول إلى المناطق الريفية مع
دعم الواقع الافتراضي
[موسيقى]
و
يريدون أن يكرزوا بالإنجيل
كان loco benestar يشير إلى توسيع نطاق
مشكلة مع التخدير
التقليدية لها بعض العيوب
من بينها التكلفة الباهظة والآثار
ضمانة أو سلبية
[موسيقى]
ويتم وضع العدسات الافتراضية
اضبط وفقًا لحجم ملف
رئيس ويقوم بتشغيل النظام
الواقع الافتراضي الذي يتم باستخدام ملف
الهاتف الخليوي حاليا أثناء
عملية نظرت إلى هذه النباتات الطبيعية
صخور الحيوانات والبيئة كانت بالفعل
انتهت الجراحة
بضع لدغات طفيفة لكنها لم تكن كذلك
ألم شديد
عادي
نخفف الألم في هؤلاء بنسبة تزيد عن 50٪
يعطي المرضى المرضى أ
أمل كبير في البقاء يمنحهم
نوعية حياة أفضل لا شيء يجعلني
يشعر بالرضا عن الشخص
بالحياة راضية عن الحياة
المهنية التي سمحت لي
تطوير نفسي رد الجميل للمجتمع
ما ولدتني
[موسيقى]